- [Devin] Are NFTs a scam or
are they the next big thing?
Legally speaking, it's a question
between Uber and Theranos.
Uber was able to sidestep regulation
to become a billion dollar company,
and basically is interwoven
into the fabric of society.
Whereas Theranos tried to
fake it until they made it,
but they ran up against
physics and biology
and were just a giant fraud.
NFTs are probably somewhere in the middle.
They're certainly not unicorns
that are going to solve all problems,
but they're probably not
all completely useless.
And either way they raise
fundamental issues of law.
So today we're going to
cover only the legal problems
associated with NFTs.
Others have explained
the non-legal issues.
For example, Dan Olson of Folding Ideas
did a fantastic video
called The Line Goes Up,
which is not to say that the technology
can't overcome these problems,
but right now there are some
fundamental issues of law
with the way that NFTs are used now.
And I see three main
categories of issues with NFTs,
on-chain problems, off-chain problems,
and what I call innovations so
mundane, no one should care.
Now, to get to those issues with NFTs,
we first have to define what an NFT is
because I think almost
everyone gets it wrong.
An NFT is a Non Fungible Token.
It is an entry on a decentralized ledger,
called a blockchain.
A blockchain is a permanent
unchangeable digital ledger
that's used to record transactions
in blocks of computer code
that are timestamped and linked together.
The code will reveal the
history of a digital asset,
where it originated,
who purchased it and any
subsequent transfers.
And in the digital world,
the token can be assigned
specific uses and properties.
Now, it's non fungible because
it is said to be unique.
Unlike something like Bitcoin,
where every single Bitcoin
is interchangeable with another one,
it's like $1 bill.
Every $1 bill that you possess
effectively does the exact same thing
as another dollar bill.
Same with a Bitcoin.
However, an NFT is said to be unique,
so they are not fungible with each other.
But at this point,
let me turn it over to someone
more technically minded,
my friend Steve Mould,
to explain how an NFT actually operates
because it's illuminating.
So Steve, how does an NFT work?
- NFTs work in a very
similar way to Bitcoins.
We track who owns what Bitcoin
on a distributed ledger,
as you mentioned.
In the case of Bitcoin,
that distributed ledger is
called the Bitcoin Blockchain,
but NFTs exist on a different blockchain,
typically the Ethereum Blockchain.
The difference between
Bitcoin and Ethereum
is that the Ethereum
blockchain is programmable.
You can write programs and publish them
to the Ethereum Blockchain.
These aren't programs that you
would run on your computer,
these programs run on the blockchain
and they interact with
transactions on the blockchain.
For example,
you could write a program and publish it
to the Ethereum Blockchain
that launches a new
cryptocurrency to rival Bitcoin.
But it's not just limited
to cryptocurrency,
you could use the Ethereum
programming language
to do all sorts of things,
including for example, making NFTs.
These programs are called smart contracts,
which is misleading because look,
here's an example of a smart contract.
There's no legal language in there.
It doesn't function as a legal document.
Though, I can see
why they wanted to call
them smart contract
because they enforce transactional
rules on the blockchain.
Just like normal software,
once you publish a smart
contract to the blockchain,
you can interact with it
by sending it commands.
For example,
you could send a command
telling it to mint a new NFT,
or you could send a command
to change the owner of an NFT.
Smart contracts can be used
for much more than just
cryptocurrency and NFTs.
For example,
you could write a smart
contract that act as an escrow
between people buying and selling NFTs.
The definition of an NFT is quite strict.
By consensus, we've agreed
that if a smart contract
behaves in certain specific ways,
as defined by a standard
called ERC721 and one other,
then we call that an NFT smart contract.
So how does all this
relate to digital art?
Well, let's have a look
at the most expensive Bored Ape ever sold,
that's Bored Ape number 2087.
Let's head over to Etherscan,
a website for exploring
the Ethereum Blockchain.
This is the address of the smart contract
that mints Bored Ape NFTs.
ERC721 contracts can be
queried in certain ways.
For example,
I can use the owner of query
to find out who owns a particular NFT.
So Bored Ape 2087 is owned by this person.
The ERC721 standard also includes
something called the token URI.
If I put 2087 in here, I get this.
This is a URI on the public
internet for anyone to see.
It's an IPFS address,
so let's head over to the Brave Browser
and see where that takes us.
This is some machine readable JSON code,
but let's make it a bit
easier to read for humans.
And look, you can see that's
URI for the ape image itself.
And here are some attributes of the ape.
For example, its mouth is bored cigarette.
The background is purple.
The fur is trippy.
The eyes are angry.
Let's grab this image URI
and stick it back into the Brave Browser.
And there it is.
So when you buy an NFT that's
linked to a digital artwork,
you are buying a unique location
on the Ethereum Blockchain,
that points to a text file on the internet
for everyone to see.
Inside that text file is another URI
that points to the image itself,
again on the internet for everyone to see.
Believe me,
there are a bunch of
weird technical details
that need to be talked about,
associated with NFTs,
I cover all of that over on my channel,
but the bottom line is,
when you buy crypto art,
you are buying a line
in a tamper-proof ledger
that points to a publicly
hosted image file.
- So at the end of the day, to summarize,
I think the best analogy for
an NFT is not digital property,
as a lot of people like to claim.
I think the best analogy
for what an NFT actually is,
is a receipt.
It is a receipt of some transaction,
a buyer and seller interacted in some way,
and an NFT is a receipt
of that transaction.
That receipt often links
to something off-chain,
often that is a JPEG.
But the receipt itself
doesn't really tell you
what the transaction was.
To know what happened in that transaction,
you have to look at the
terms of the original sale,
the contract.
You also have to look
at the reference work,
often that's a JPEG.
But the NFT itself is simply
a entry in a digital ledger,
that's kind of like a
receipt in the real world.
Okay, so with that understanding,
I think we can get to the first
category of legal problems
associated with NFTs,
which are the problems
that are inherent on chain.
And for that, I'm afraid
we're going to have to talk
about fundamental contract theory.
Honestly, I didn't think that this video
was going to require me
to get back to first
principles of contract law,
the kind of thing that you learned
in your first year of law
school, and yet here we are.
And we need to understand
how a contract works,
how it binds the parties
and what the limitations of contracts are.
And I know that sounds super boring,
but I'm going to explain that
with wrestler and
Renaissance man, John Cena,
because in 2017,
John Cena contracted with
the Ford Motor Company
to buy the new Ford GT,
the new hottest sports car at the time.
In order for him to buy that car,
he formed a contract with Ford.
He offered to pay them hundreds
of thousands of dollars
and Ford offered to give him a Ford GT.
But in particular,
there was one term that Ford
included in the sales contract,
John Cena had to agree
not to sell his Ford GT
for two years.
And that as a perfectly
enforceable sale contract.
Ford doesn't have to sell that to anyone.
And so to make sure that
John Cena didn't turn around,
flip the car for hundreds
of thousands of dollars,
they made him promise not to
sell the car for two years.
What did John Cena do?
He turned her around and flipped
the car almost immediately
and made hundreds of thousands of dollars.
So what could Ford Motor Company do?
Ford could sue John Cena
for hundreds of thousands of dollars.
And in fact, they did sue him
and they settled for
an undisclosed amount.
But the really interesting question is,
what can Ford do against the person
that bought the car from John Cena?
And the answer is absolutely nothing
because there's no contract between Ford
and the person that bought
the car from John Cena.
The secondary buyer is said to
not be in privity with Ford.
John Cena and Ford are in privity,
they have an actual contract,
but there's nothing linking Ford
and the downstream purchaser.
So what in the world does
this have to do with NFTs?
Well here's the thing,
we talked about how an NFT
doesn't really have any
attributes in and of itself.
When you're buying an NFT,
the real thing that you're buying
is bound by the contract between
the buyer and the seller,
those are the primary
purchaser and seller.
There are some times when
there is no contract,
we'll talk about that.
But theoretically at least,
the value of the NFT is
decided by the contract terms
between the buyer and
the seller of the NFT.
But one of the huge fundamental problems
that we'll talk about a lot in a second,
is that in practice,
there's rarely any contract
between the initial primary
buyer and the secondary buyers,
and then all of the
downstream buyers later on.
And on top of that,
there is zero contractual privity
between secondary buyers and
the original issuer of the NFT.
That's a real problem
when the only value associated with an NFT
comes from the initial sale terms.
So let's talk about an
example of this in practice.
Many people are familiar
with NBA Top Shots,
which was designed by Dapper Labs.
NBA Top Shots is an NBA platform
that purports to allow you to own moments
that happen in the NBA,
often small snippets of
videos related to NBA plays.
Now, when you buy an NBA Top Shot NFT,
the transaction's registered
on the flow blockchain,
which was basically
created out of whole cloth
by Dapper Labs to
facilitate the transactions
of NBA Top Shots.
When you initially buy an NBA Top Shot,
you get limited rights to use
and view the NBA Top Shot,
only within the NBA Top Shots platform.
But here's the thing.
NBA Top Shots is a private marketplace.
The NFTs only have any real value
when you use the walled
garden of NBA Top Shots,
you have to use their app or their website
for the NFT to have any
functionality at all.
But in a way it works
because everyone is on the same platform.
Effectively NBA Top Shots is
simply a normal Web 2.0 website
where you're allowed
to buy and sell things
only within their specific platform.
And the terms of sale travel
with the particular NFTs
because everyone is buying
into the same system.
If you somehow got an NBA Top Shot NFT
and was able to sell it
on a different blockchain,
well, odds are the terms
and conditions don't flow
and you have an NFT that
has zero value at all,
because it won't even work
with the original NBA Top Shots platform.
So if you are not NBA Top Shots
and you're not forcing everyone
to use the same walled garden,
how do you buy the secondary purchasers?
How do you even know what you're buying
when you're buying an NFT?
Well, that is incredibly controversial.
Now, another famous example
is the Bored Ape Yacht Club
that is famous for selling
NFTs of monkey cartoons.
Now, you can buy a Bored
Ape NFT on OpenSea,
which is a large marketplace for NFTs.
When you do,
the Bored Ape Yacht Club
says that you get access to certain perks.
These include getting access
to their discord server
of like-minded purchasers of Bored Apes.
But for the most part,
those are perks that are offered off-chain
and by the originator of the NFTs.
Bored Ape could change their mind
because it's questionable
whether the terms and conditions
travel with the downstream purchasers
of every single Bored Ape.
If those terms and
conditions legally fail,
say Bored Ape says they're not in privity
with all of those downstream purchasers,
and then they decide to cut off access
to maybe some bad actors
who were spamming the Bored Ape discord.
Well, then those purchasers
who spent hundreds of
thousands of dollars,
they have zero recourse,
because if they're not
in contractual privity,
there's nothing that binds Bored Ape
to provide those things long term.
They may in fact provide those things,
but they might not legally be required to.
Now, if you're a normal website,
you'd probably provide what's
called a click wrap agreement.
That's one of those contracts
that you scroll through
and then click I agree.
Well, that provides a whole
bunch of terms and conditions.
Sometimes those bind the users,
sometimes that binds the platform itself.
Now, when it comes to NFTs,
you could provide a click wrap agreement,
I don't see that being done very much.
But there's a fundamental problem,
the agreement isn't necessarily
linked to the NFT itself.
You could also theoretically
put the terms of sale
in the reference work
that's held off-chain.
But again,
that is something that is not necessarily
connected to the NFT itself,
it can change over time.
And you still have no
guarantee that the buyer
has read the terms when
the sale is consummated.
And as you have more and
more secondary purchasers
and you get further and further
away from the initial sale,
the problems just get harder and harder
to make sure that all of
the downstream purchasers
saw and assented to all
of the contract terms
and to make sure that the prior sellers
and the original minter
are bound by the same terms
to provide the thing
that was origin provided
when the NFT was minted.
And the fundamental question,
if you buy an NFT
that doesn't have any
sale terms whatsoever,
what have you purchased?
The answer is probably nothing.
At least nothing that the law can protect.
We'll talk about this later,
but one of the off-chain
problems with NFTs
is that the reference work can change,
you can get rug pulled.
And if you don't have a contract
that says you are entitled
to one specific thing,
well, the NFT doesn't tell
you what the thing was
that you were supposed to buy.
In a way, an NFT is like a hyperlink
and you can't own a hyperlink.
So if you buy an NFT that
doesn't have contract terms,
it doesn't define what you have purchased
and you aren't familiar with
the terms of conditions,
and you want to try and enforce that NFT
against someone that
you purchased it from,
I'm afraid to tell you that
I think you own about as much
as a hyperlink,
which is to say you can't own that.
Many people claim that NFTs
supplant copyright law entirely.
And unfortunately that's not even close.
NFTs are a product of contract law,
extremely fundamental
ideas of contract law.
And there are real problems
when it comes to enforcing those contracts
and creating privity
between the original minter
and downstream purchasers.
Now, one of the things that NFTs can do,
is that they can be attributed
with some basic programming,
so called smart contracts.
Now, these smart contracts
are basically contracts
in the same sense that a
microchip is a contract,
it's not a legally binding document,
it just has a bit of
programming to do things
when certain conditions are met.
And these smart contracts seem to well
when they are based on
internet native occurrences
and simple transactions,
the kind of thing like an escrow account
where you don't release funds
until certain conditions
precedent are met.
But these smart contracts,
these tiny programs
are not real contracts,
they don't bind the downstream purchasers.
And in fact, as we've seen,
they can break over time.
There are no legal rights that are created
as a result of the smart
contracts themselves.
So for better or worse,
lawyers exist for a reason,
and programmers are really, really bad
at planning for contingencies.
And they're also really bad
at understanding contract law in general.
So the bottom line is that
NFTs are a product of contract,
the terms under which you bought them.
So for all of those who purchased in NFTs,
I'm sure that you all checked
the terms and conditions
before you purchased, right?
You got terms and conditions, right?
And that brings us to copyright
because NFTs do not
supplant copyright law,
not even close.
NFTs are bound by normal
everyday rules of copyright.
When you buy an NFT,
sometimes you get the copyright,
but most of the times you don't.
Again, it entirely depends
on the original terms of
sale related to the NFT.
NBA Top shots for example,
does not give you a copyright
in the original video
to the NBA.
They give you an extremely limited license
to use that video in
extremely limited places
and nothing more.
Some other famous examples
where people think they're
buying the copyright,
but aren't include CryptoAds
and Bored Ape Yacht Club.
With CryptoAds, they basically operate
under the Creative Commons Zero License,
where if you buy a CryptoAds JPEG,
they allow you to do basically
whatever you want with them.
But again, CryptoAds hangs
on to the original copyright.
They simply license it
to downstream purchasers.
Same thing with the Bored Ape Yacht Club,
they offer a fairly expansive license,
but again, they hold the IP centrally.
And you're just simply given a license.
You are not buying the copyright
associated with the Bored Ape
cartoon that you purchased.
And with Bored Ape, the
license is held off-chain,
which means that that license
might change over time
and you might never even know about it.
And often this has very little
to do with copyright at all.
If you buy an NBA Top Shot,
let's say of a particular clip
of something that happened in the NBA,
you can't enforce that against someone
who is displaying that piece
of video somewhere else.
And on top of that,
the NBA can prevent you from displaying
that particular video clip,
if you're displaying it in a way
that conflicts with the license
that was purchased through NBA Top Shots,
which again is incredibly restrictive.
And the issue of copyright
is incredibly important
because when you're
talking about digital art,
that's often the only right
that the law recognizes.
If you don't have the copyright,
then you effectively have nothing.
And that's important because
in a context of NFTs,
a lot of the art that
is being bought and sold
probably doesn't have a copyright at all,
it's copyrightable.
The ultimate irony is that
when it comes to digital art
that does have a copyright,
ironically, the copyright
is a scarce resource.
There's only one.
Sure you can license it an
infinite number of times,
or you can assign the copyright,
but the copyright itself
is inherently scarce.
And maybe we never needed to solve
the digital scarcity question at all,
because it was already solved
through regular copyright law.
Because a lot of the reference art
that's associated with an
NFT is called generative art.
It's art that's created by AI,
or programmatically through a computer.
You might have heard of
the Ninth Circuit Case,
Naruto versus Slater.
That is the monkey selfie case
where the courts recognize that
only a human can create art
that has a copyright.
In that particular case,
there was a monkey
that got a hold of a photographer's
camera, took a selfie,
and the photographer
tried exercise a copyright
in that particular piece of artwork.
At the same time,
PETA said that the monkey
owned the copyright
to that particular photo,
and they intervened to try to
exercise the monkey's rights
on its behalf.
And the court found that
no one had a copyright
because only humans can
have a copyright in art.
Only humans can create
art that is copyrightable.
So by extension,
if a machine is deemed to
be the author of a work,
no one can exercise a copyright
in that particular artwork.
And in the context of NFTs,
there's untold numbers of works
that are touted as being
created by computers
that's deemed to be a feature, not a bug.
And if that's the case,
I don't think that there is a
copyright there to begin with.
No one can exercise any rights
associated with that artwork
because no human created it.
Even with a very famous
Bored Ape Yacht Club,
it seems to be just a rehashing
of the same elements over
and over and over again,
which I believe were hashed by a computer
rather than person.
A person may have created
the individual elements
once upon a time,
but the individual artworks
were created by a computer.
Now there are some complicated issues
related to copyrights of
compilations and works for hire,
but there is an argument
that some very, very expensive NFTs
simply don't have a copyright at all.
Now in fairness to
NFTs, in the real world,
when you buy real art, you
buy a physical painting,
it's normal not to buy the copyright
associated with that particular painting.
When you buy a novel,
you are not buying the copyright
associated with that novel.
So it's not unusual in the art world
to not get the copyright
associated with a work.
And so, in some sense,
it's normal not to get a copyright
associated with digital art.
The issue here is that digital art
doesn't have a physical token.
If you aren't getting
the copyright associated
with the digital art,
you're not really getting anything
that is protectable under the law.
But of course, in the real world,
you actually have a physical thing.
And that's associated
with a legal doctrine
called the First Sale Doctrine
that when you buy a physical good,
whether it is a painting
or a pair of Nike shoes,
you can basically do whatever you want
to that physical good.
You don't have necessarily
the right to reproduce
or otherwise use an image
of the thing that you have purchased,
but you do have the right
to basically do whatever you want
with the physical good itself,
including selling it to somebody else.
Physical works of art are almost
inherently scarce as well.
A painting can only be
painted by a human once.
And NFTs are touted as solving
the infinite reproducibility
problem with digital works.
Where legally speaking at least,
no NFT can claim to have
Providence over an artwork
that is itself legally
infinitely reproducible.
So when it comes to
digital art, such as JPEGs,
if you're not buying the copyright,
I'm not sure legally what you are buying.
And as a non-legal aside,
I know art is inherently subjective
and there's no objectivity in art
and claiming that something
is good art or bad art
is inherently inchoate,
but I mean, just look at
this stuff, this is bad art.
And if you're claiming that this art
is inherently worth hundreds
of thousands of dollars,
apart from an any speculative value,
I don't think you're good at art.
So that takes us to
consumer protection issues.
We've seen that there is a vast Gulf
between what people think they are getting
and what they're actually
getting when it comes to NFTs.
And these NFTs are widely promoted
by a wide variety of different people,
including the people that
are selling these things
and people who are paid to promote them.
And it doesn't seem
that anyone really knows
exactly what they are receiving.
Platforms like NBA Top Shots,
who you can assume have
legions of lawyers,
have actually changed a lot
of the marketing language
that they've used.
Historically they used
language like owning a moment,
but that probably doesn't line up
with the idea of getting an
extremely limited IP license
to view and display the reference work,
almost exclusively on
the Top Shots platform.
Now they use language like scoring in NFT,
or collecting in NFT,
which to me, is very, very different
than the idea of owning a moment.
And it almost goes without
saying, but I'll say it anyway,
you can't own a moment,
that is not a thing
that the law recognizes
that anyone can own.
You might as well try and buy
a star in a far away galaxy,
you can't own that.
And it seems like there is a
huge amount of misperception
in terms of what people
think they're getting
in terms of ownership.
And of course the false promises
from the minters are
compounding that effect.
And whenever you have
false promises from sellers
and misperceptions of buyers,
you run into consumer protection issues.
If I was a minter or a seller of NFTs,
I'd make darn sure that
every single person
saw the terms and conditions,
so that there was no confusion
as to what I was selling
and what they were buying,
but that's just simply not
happening in this industry.
And while many people would
probably try and claim
first amendment protection,
the first amendment does
not extend nearly as much
to buyers and sellers of goods.
When you have commercial
sales and commercial speech,
the first amendment doesn't
protect nearly as much
as you'd think it would.
And as we discussed,
many NFTs drop without
any terms whatsoever.
And for those that do have terms,
it's not at all clear
that those terms travel
with downstream purchasers
of those NFTs.
NFTs are also a product of programming.
And as we've seen time and time again,
those programs can fail.
An NFT can be corrupted,
the reference work can be rug pulled,
you can change the reference work,
even if you're pointing to an IPFS file,
that can change.
Who's responsible if the
NFT isn't even delivering
the things that it was
supposed to deliver,
if those terms exist?
Often NFTs provide the
division of royalties
and revenue streams,
but those often only work if
the blockchain is working.
You better hope that the
blockchain doesn't fork,
that the programming works
and that it provides for
every single contingency
that you can think of,
because those things break all the time.
And there are all kinds of laws
that make sure that
consumers are protected
by contracts of adhesion.
There is the ESIGN act
that governs whether a click
wrap agreement on a website
is enforceable, both against
the seller and to the buyer.
These are effectively the
se same kinds of issues
that any kind of eCommerce website
is going to have to deal with.
But effectively every single
individual buyer and seller
of an NFT have to deal
with the same thing,
and many people just aren't.
Making sure that contract
terms are enforceable
is a known issue that all websites,
whether it's Web 2.0 or Web 3,
have to deal with.
And you might try and put
a contract on OpenSea,
if that is the marketplace
that you are trying to sell your NFT,
but right now there's no guarantee
that anyone's going to read it.
And if no one's reading
the contract terms,
you've got big issues in
terms of enforceability,
let alone privity.
And the bottom line is
that you have to make sure
that consumer are affirmatively consenting
to the contract terms.
And if you can't prove that
that might be your problem,
but it also might be the
problem of the NFT purchasers.
If they wanna make sure that third parties
are providing off-chain unlocked goods,
well, you'd better have a
contract that makes sure
that they actually provide those things.
And then there's all kinds
of securities related legal issues.
NFTs are being market mostly
as art or collectibles,
but at the same time,
there is so much hype
and so much speculation,
people tout them at as incredible
investment opportunities,
premised on the idea
that they will always increase in value.
At the moment it's incredibly unclear,
but it's possible that the
Securities Exchange Commission,
the SEC, could classify
certain NFTs as security.
If they are classified as securities,
this triggers all kinds
of regulatory issues
with potential liabilities.
And while it currently unclear,
courts will use what's
called the Howey Test
to determine whether these
things are securities or not.
That stems from a Supreme Court case.
Under this test,
a transaction is deemed an
investment contract if a person,
"Invest his money in a common enterprise
"and is led to expect profits
solely from the efforts
"of the promoter or a third party."
This was a huge problem for the ICO,
the Initial Coin Offering boom of 2017,
because those Initial Coin Offerings
ran a foul of the Howey Test
and were regulated as securities.
Effectively, people offered
coins on a blockchain,
related to some enterprise,
for a thing that had not
yet been and created.
And as a result,
you rarely see Initial
Coin Offerings anymore,
at least not from companies
that are trying to abide by the law.
Now, the argument against NFTs securities
is that NFTs are finished products,
not investment vehicles
that need to be managed.
If NFTs appreciate in value,
it's through principles like scarcity
and just market forces,
not because of a third party's effort
to enhance the NFTs value.
And the SEC's 2019 framework says,
"Price appreciation
"resulting solely from
external market forces,
"such as general inflationary
trends or the economy,
"impacting the supply and
demand of an underlying asset,
"generally is not considered
profit under Howey Test."
So an increase in value alone
doesn't make something a security.
However, some of the proposed uses of NFTs
are a much closer call
and would probably be
considered securities
if push came to shove.
Things like royalty payments to artists,
especially if the art
hasn't been created yet,
would be a much closer call.
And even apart from
securities related regulation,
there seems to be all kinds
of just garden variety fraud.
The NFT markets are rife
with rug pulls and Rickrolls,
people who are intentionally
scamming other people
out of hundreds of thousands,
if not millions of dollars.
Not in the sense that NFTs
in general are a scam,
but literally these
things are actual scams
where they're making false promises,
knowing that they're false
and then not providing
on the thing that they promise to provide.
I mean, that is just
good old fashioned fraud.
But don't take my word for it,
I turn to the foremost expert
in crypto related scams,
Coffeezilla, to give me
a recent salient example.
- One example of when
an NFT project promised
and then didn't deliver
on what it said it would,
was De'Aaron Fox's project,
called SwipaTheFox.
De'Aaron is an NBA player
for the Sacramento Kings
and he recently pulled in
$1.5 million in NFT sales,
in part due to a roadmap
where he had promised
some pretty extraordinary things,
which would give these NFTs
some real world utility.
For example,
one of the perks was gonna be
a Metaverse basketball court,
five scholarships, charity
giveaways, free merch,
even tickets to All Star games.
These all gave investors the impression
that these NFTs might
have real world value
and be worth buying.
However, right after the money came in,
De'Aaron Fox issued a statement
saying he was too busy with his NBA career
to make all that happen and
was quitting the project.
No refunds, of course.
Apparently he wasn't too
busy to start the NFT,
just too busy to deliver
on what he promised.
- Then of course, there's all
kinds market manipulations.
Many of the high dollar
amount transactions
related to very high ticket NFTs,
are not conducted by
arms length transactions.
They might be wash sales,
where an individual sells
an NFT to themselves,
using a sock puppet,
or there might be coordination
between two different people
who agree to pay a high
price for something
to prop up the price.
Because the blockchain is quasi anonymous,
pseudo anonymous if you
want to get technical,
it's very easy for people to
create sock puppet accounts,
that they control,
so that they can show a price history
of their NFT being sold
for lots and lots of money,
so that some unsuspecting
downstream purchaser thinks,
well, if that person paid this much,
then I'll pay even more
and I'll be able to sell it
to somebody else down the
line for even more than that.
Now, this to me raises garden
variety issues of fraud.
It's just out and out fraud
and market manipulation.
It could even be a violation
of the Sherman Antitrust Act.
This is the kind of anti-competitive
behavior that the DOJ and
FTC likes to crack down on.
And often when you get
into price manipulation
among several different people,
well, then you're getting
into criminal liability
under the Sherman Act.
Maybe there's an infinite
supply of greater fools
when the prices keep going up,
but as soon as any particular NFT crashes
and a buyer realizes that
there was price manipulation
before they purchased their NFT,
they might come looking
for some heads to roll,
and there might be some real
civil and criminal liability
associated with people
who were propping up the prices unfairly.
And then there's lots of
just pump and dump schemes.
People who maybe aren't
promoting an out and out scam,
but are looking to a quick buck.
And there's right now
a proposed class action
against people who promoted Ethereum Max,
people like Kim Kardashian,
Floyd Mayweather, Paul Pierce,
they promoted this token on
their social media chains,
and right now there's a class action
because it was clearly
a pump and dump scheme.
And the Ethereum Max lawsuit
doesn't rely on federal securities law,
it relies on pretty normal
state based causes of action,
like unjust enrichment,
violations of California's
Unfair Competition Law
and the California Consumer
Legal Remedies Act.
I don't know that we will
ever know for certain
how many NFTs are sold in wash sales,
how many people are trying
to drive up the price
of these things,
but anyone who is
manipulating the market here,
really faces some truly
terrifying civil liability
and maybe jail time.
And those are just the on-chain problems,
that takes us to the off-chain problems
associated with NFTs.
The first of which is
you need to make sure
that if you're selling an NFT,
you have the rights to the reference work.
Recently, an NFT minter called Hitpiece,
purported to issue an NFT
related to every song
on Spotify's database.
So they would effectively
take the album artwork
and mint NFT related to the
artist and name of the song.
It seems like that raises some
very truly terrifying issues
in terms of Hitpiece not
owning any of the rights
associated with any of the songs, artists,
or album artwork associated with the NFTs
that they claim to be making.
Now, interestingly,
there is a novel issue of copyright here.
Since the NFT doesn't contain
the musical work itself,
there's an open question
whether these NFTs violate
the musical copyright.
I'd argue they probably do,
but that's a separate issue.
And on top of that,
there is no question that minting an NFT
related to a band and their song,
using all of those names
and their album work,
certainly violate the trademark
related to this particular band and song
and probably a myriad of other
attribution related legal issues as well.
Then there was another
music related NFT project,
called Streamer.fm,
that claimed that
because you could stream
music on Spotify and YouTube,
they were somehow allowed
to mint these NFTs
and re-stream the music,
which is not how any of this works at all.
Fundamentally here,
clearing the rights and making
sure you have the rights
to mint the NFT in the first place,
goes back to old fashioned
boring concepts of contract
and copyright law.
NFT and blockchain technology,
not only doesn't supplant or replace
those bedrock principles of law,
they often run head long right into it.
And when it comes to this Corpus
of Law and brand new NFTs,
NFTs are gonna lose.
But there's all kinds of
minting NFTs without permission.
And often you have no way of knowing
whether the original minter had the rights
and the clearances to mint the
NFTs that they are minting.
Proponents of NFTs claim
that NFTs can prove digital provenance
related to works of art,
but the truth is often you have no idea
if the original minter
has any of the rights
associated with the
work in the first place.
And there's absolutely no way to know,
except through conducting an investigation
completely off-chain.
This is actually one of the issues
associated with the Quintin
Tarantino and Miramax case.
In that case, Quentin
Tarantino, the director,
was trying to min some NFTs
related to film Pulp Fiction.
And it's a complete miras
to try and figure this out
because Tarantino retains some rights
to the screenplay of
the movie Pulp Fiction,
but Miramax retains
almost all of the rights
associated with the movie itself.
And it's going to take a lot of litigation
to figure out who owns what rights
and who has the right to make NFTs
related to either the
screenplay or the movie itself.
And good luck if you think the NFT itself
is going to prove the answer
to either of those questions.
And of course,
there's all kinds of good old
fashioned regulatory risk.
A lot of people have explained
that an NFT or a blockchain
might make perfect sense
in the context of say real estate title,
where having a public
decentralized blockchain
of who buys and sells houses
could actually be much better
than the current system of
a centralized title system.
But good luck trying to
convince a state or municipality
to adopt that.
And if your blockchain
runs into something that's
already highly regulated,
like real estate title,
you can't wave a magic wand
and force the government
to adopt your technical solution,
even if your technical
solution has some benefits
over the universally adopted system.
One of the biggest issues is,
as a downstream purchaser,
how do you make sure that you can enforce
all of the terms against
the previous per purchasers
and the original NFT minter?
But the problem also goes
the other way as well.
If those terms do travel down that chain,
let's say that you are a
band or a YouTube creator,
and as part of your NFT,
you issue some sort of unlockable content
like a meet and greet with a band,
and based on the terms of sale,
anyone who ever purchases
that particular NFT
has the right to enforce a meet
and greet against the band.
Well, as the seller,
are you prepared to offer a meet and greet
with every single person
who ever purchases that NFT down the line?
Because depending on
the terms of the sale,
you might be obligated to provide that.
Otherwise you might get
hit with things like,
breach of contract or fraud,
depending on the value of the thing
that you have promised to provide.
I was talking to a very
large YouTube creator
who wanted to create an NFT.
I'm not going to name him,
but I am going to wish him congratulations
when he passes a hundred
billion subscribers
in just a little while,
and he wanted to offer a video conference
with whoever purchased
this NFT 24 hours a day,
365 days out of the year.
And I suggested to him that
maybe that wasn't a good idea,
unless he liked being woken
up in the middle of the night
and being forced to
provide a video conference
with every single person
who purchased his NFT.
And lo and behold, he
didn't go through with it,
and I think that was a smart thing.
I've seen lots of people claim
that there is absolutely no downside
to creators creating their own NFTs.
On the contrary, there's all
kinds of potential pitfalls
if you not smart about these things.
Then there's things like
product liabilities,
NFTs break all the time.
Who's responsible if
the link between the NFT
and the reference material breaks?
Who's responsible if the blockchain forks
and your revenue stream is then cut off?
These are bedrock ideas
of product liability,
on top of which it's not at all clear,
from the blockchain itself,
that the thing isn't functioning.
You've gotta do an
investigation off the blockchain
to know if the thing
that's on the blockchain
is actually working or not.
There's been a lot of
talk about minting NFTs
related to real world goods,
creating an NFT related to a house
to track who buys and sells the house,
creating NFT related to a car,
related to the car itself.
But what happens when something
happens in the real world
that isn't reflected on the blockchain?
What happens if the house burns down?
What happens if the car gets stolen?
Rectifying real world events
with things on the blockchain
is no easy task and is
inherently off-chain.
And there are other
unintended consequences
along with this as well.
For example, Alfa Romeo just said
that they're going to are offering NFTs
related to their cars.
And when you take your Alfa Romeo car
into being serviced with Alfa Romeo,
there will be a history on the blockchain
that shows that your car was serviced
at such and such a time
in such and such a way
and that follows with the car.
But one of the problems
is what happens if you take your car
to a non-authorized dealer,
that information won't make it
onto the Alfa Romeo blockchain.
It's one way that Alfa
Romeo might force you
to use their walled garden.
It'd be like DRM for a car,
you'd never be able to take your car
to any other service place.
Now, I am not a computer programmer,
these might be technical problems
that will be fixed over time.
Already we're seeing
intermediaries like OpenSea,
interpret the data on blockchain
and solve some of the issues
when it comes to falsely minted NFTs.
But if that's the case
and we need these intermediaries
that are off-chain,
it raises the question
Why would we want Web 3?
In fact, we can do all
of this stuff legally
using traditional websites and
traditional legal mechanisms.
Often the Web 3 part of it
just makes things worse.
Which takes us to the third
category of problems with NFTs,
which I've called innovation so mundane
that no one should care.
And the issue here
is that there are probably
plenty of marginal benefits
that NFTs bring to the table
for a wide variety of industries,
they're just not huge wins
that are going to create an
enormous amount of wealth
for the people with vested interests.
It's pretty clear that
collectible JPEGs are pretty dumb
and that this is a speculative bubble
with untold numbers of non
arm length transactions,
wash sales and sock puppets.
It's pretty clear at this point
that at least this
first generation of NFTs
are creating a speculative bubble
that is probably going to
burst pretty violently.
Collectible JPEGs
and other collectible
digital pieces of artwork,
it's probably not going to last.
It's pretty dumb
and I think people will
probably get bored with it.
It's also filled with all kinds
of non arm length transactions,
wash sales and sock puppets
that are propping up the prices
and just waiting for another
person to come around
and buy the thing that probably
isn't worth the sales price.
But that being said,
there are probably lots of other uses
that are more promising,
fractionalized revenue streams,
access to unique membership
style opportunities,
proving certain kinds of
Providence and raising equity.
But the thing is those
uses of NFTs are genuine,
but they're really just
marginal improvements
on current technology,
if they are indeed improvements at all.
And NFT acolytes are claiming
NFTs are a grand slam,
but it's probably probably more
like a simple walk on single.
These improvements in
technology are probably useful,
but they're also extremely mundane.
The technology at use here
probably will form some
of the unseen backbone
of certain transactions,
but it just simply won't
be get rich quick schemes.
It seems likely that the huge market
for NFTs as collectibles will
probably crash at some point.
And when the bubble around JPEGs dies out,
what will be left is probably a technology
that makes marginal improvements.
It's going to create a few millionaires,
maybe even billionaires
who find novel and practical
uses for this technology,
but it's not going to create
overnight millionaires
for everyone that wants to mint
some low value NFT going forward.
And the reason that that
is a problem for NFTs,
is that there are many, many people
who have staked their entire reputations,
as well as their entire finances,
on the proposition that NFTs have created
a completely new industry
and that it can create overnight
millionaires in anyone.
And when people realize
that that's not the case,
well, the entire industry
may evaporate a overnight,
faster than Beanie Babies.
Now, of course,
NFTs are heralded as this
revolution in creator economics,
as a way for artists to actually
paid what they're worth,
but people don't realize
that there's real liability
and that NFTs could be
incredibly dangerous
if not outright terrible for creators.
I go into great detail based
on my experience as a lawyer,
but also my experience
as a creator myself.
Let's just say,
there's a reason I haven't
minted any NFTs myself.
Now, what if I told you
that you could watch
another LegalEagle video,
but this time it's on why
NFTs could be dangerous
and bad for creators.
Well, this full length
companion video does exist
and it is exclusively on Nebula.
Because sadly, if I put it on YouTube,
it would probably get demonetized
and there's no way you'd ever see it.
But Nebula is different.
As you've probably heard by now,
Nebula is home to tons of
exclusive ad free content,
like my first full length
documentary, Bad Law Words Good,
a long form interview with Mark Rober,
exclusive videos on legal rights
you should definitely use,
and anti-SLAPP laws in Kyle
Rittenhouse, plus tons more.
And all of this exclusive
content is only on Nebula,
which you can get for free
with Curiosity Stream.
Of course, the reason why all these videos
are only available on Nebula,
is because they just wouldn't
work here on YouTube.
They'd never be viewed
because of the way that the site works.
But on the other hand,
Nebula is a different
platform with no algorithm
and without any ads,
because Nebula is a place where
can experiment with content,
put things on there that
we couldn't put on YouTube.
Nebula is a platform for
great and unique content
made by independent educational creators
that you probably already know,
like Tom Scott, Thomas
Frank, and Thomas Flight,
as well as lots of other
people not named Tom,
like Half As Interesting,
Marques Brownlee,
RealLifeLore, Wendover Productions,
Mike Boyd, MinuteEarth, Neo,
Real Engineering, Knowing Better,
and so many others.
There's tons of exclusive content
released multiple times every day.
And Nebula is creator owned and operated
and we've been developing like crazy.
Nebula now has apps for iOS, Android,
Apple TV, Roku, Fire TV, and Android TV.
And we're thrilled to be
partnering with Curiosity Stream
because they're the go-to source
for the best documentaries and
long form educational content
on the internet.
They even have an entire section devoted
to unsolved mysteries in crime.
So if you like my videos,
you'll love the stuff on Curiosity Stream.
And the best way to get access to Nebula
and all of this incredible content
is definitely through
the amazing Curiosity
Stream Nebula bundle.
With it's current sales
price of less than $15
for the entire year,
which gives you access to both sites.
And to be clear that Nebula
subscription is not a trial,
it's free for long as you're
a Curiosity Stream member.
There just isn't a better
deal in streaming anywhere,
and you get two great streaming sites
with content you'll
actually watch and enjoy.
And what's more,
signing up will actually help
countless independent educational creators
beyond just LegalEagle.
So sign up right now by
clicking on the button
that's on screen right now,
which will take you directly
to CuriosityStream.com/LegalEagle
to sign up.
Or you can click on the link
that's down below in the description.
It's a great way to
support educational content
and get tons of exclusive
content that you'll love.
So go watch it right now,
or you can click on
this playlist over here
with all of my other real law reviews.
So click on one of these links
or I'll see you in court.